hello everyone and welcome to a
spectacular game from The Challengers
section of this year's Tata steel I'm
sure you guys were expecting a game by
Magnus or ding or one of the uh big fish
from the uh from the Masters Edition but
after you see this game you will
understand why I decided to start with
the the Challenger section in this game
between Max Varma Dominic with perhaps
we've seen a game by both of them at
least once on this channel and even uh I
think two years ago around this time uh
we I had a video titled the greatest
Queen sacrifice of 2021 uh oh uh which
was also played by Max vermerdam uh so
it's a very interesting uh I I guess he
just gets very inspired by January or or
something so let's dive straight into
this game and uh to make matters even
more interesting I didn't even have to
change the name all that much as the
previous video I made was by the former
world champion Max so you know it's
always nice when things work out now
let's dive straight into it marks with
the white pieces opens with E4 we have
Pawn to E5 Knight to F3 Knight the C6
and the bishop to B5 he goes for the rui
Lopez uh but not really you you'll see
what I mean by this with Knight gte7 not
uh something that you will see very
often in top level play uh but it it is
very solid this is the cause your
defense and usually uh castles or C3
will be played here and Max goes for
Knight to C3 we have Knight to G6 now
adding more Defenders to the E5 pawn and
now uh the standard moves here are D4
and H4 those are the moves you you will
usually see here but Max plays Bishop
back to C4 it's sort of a wasting a
Tempo move and if you ask the engine
it's not a very good one the engine says
okay you just wasted a Tempo but as
you'll see it's not easy to tackle this
is only move 5 and already as of move
five we have a completely new game so
here at Bishop to C5 black is very happy
with this bishop to C4 move now black is
not behind in development at all we have
pawned the H4 preparing to kick away the
knight from G6 with Ponte H6 and now
Knight to D5 so just putting everything
uh up there to attack the black king we
have Knight G2 E7 you could also
consider castling here it's not a
problem but first um you know that H5 is
coming so you might as well tackle the
Knight on D5 we have C3 and now uh
castles by guy we have Knight the G5
already going for for the black king and
the the idea is a pretty standard one if
H captures on G5 uh you're gonna play
Knight to F6 check and completely mess
up a black spawn structure here captures
captures and there is no defense against
Queen to H5 Queen to H7 Checkmate
doesn't really matter what you do even
even if you try this uh Queen H5 and
Rook date then you have Queen captures
and F7 Checkmate that's why the bishop
on C4 is so much better than on B5 even
on move 3 if you're deciding whether to
go for the Italian or or the real Lopez
but okay seems that it'll also works
with being down a Tempo but it's not uh
it's not forced or anything just Knight
captures on D5 e captures on D5 and now
uh you have two good options here you
have Knights the E7 or you have Fawn to
B5 Fanta B5 was played in the game uh
but we're gonna discuss what happens if
Knight the E7 then the idea is Pawn to
D6 now opening up the F5 uh the uh sorry
this diagonal for the bishop and after
Bishop captures or C captures doesn't
really matter Queen to F3 now with a
triple attack on the F7 pawn and once
you defend it now look at this D4 you
even allowed the e-file to open up and
after captures okay black is now
threatening some nasty discover is King
to F1 and I mean look at this position
not something you you would expect to
see in such a such a top level game uh
so okay uh and the white of course would
have a very nice attack here so instead
after e captures and D5 B5 is played now
of course if Bishop captures on B5 you
no longer have to worry about the bishop
being on this diagonal so Bishop to B3
and now Knight to A5 trying to eliminate
this bishop is it's an immensely Strong
attacking piece so Bishop back to C2 and
now comes Knight to B7 Bishop to B6 is a
bit more precise because you have to
worry about that pawn being pushed the
at the B4 you usually have to worry
about this in this position in
particular but Knights the B7 was played
and now Queen to H5
again uh of course there is no hope in
capturing the Knight we have Pawn to D6
and now Pawn to D4 attacking the bishop
e captures on D4 and now look at this uh
probably you're expecting something like
King to F1 as that's what we were
discussing um uh in in the previous
states of the game but here Max just
castles he says I no longer need the
rook and the H file because my bishop
and C2 is strong enough uh so Ponte F5
you have to close this diagonal
otherwise you're just gonna get
destroyed and now Knight the F3 uh this
is not the only move for Max there's
also Rook to E1 and you can give up the
Knight but uh of course black would not
uh take the Knight but maybe Rook to E1
uh grabbing hold of the E6 square and
then planting the Knight on E6 as the
the pawn cannot be the Knight cannot be
captured we're just gonna play G6 and
Checkmate the black king but Max has a
different idea he plays Knight to F3 now
comes the characters on C3 uh opening up
this diagonal for the bishop also a very
strong move and now Max plays Bishop
captures on H6 and Can you capture this
bishop well you could but then you allow
Queen to G6 check and then white at
least has a draw a white at least has a
draw if not more because white always
has the perpetual and it's only a matter
of if white is able to yeah pull off a
Checkmate so here C captures on B2 first
threatening to capture the rook and now
Max plays Rook 8 to E1 I will just show
you another fun line that starts with
Bishop captures on G7 there's no point
in capturing The Rook even though you
get a second Queen because Bishop
captures and now you cannot avoid being
destroyed here so what you would have to
do is play King captures on G7 and now
Knight to G5 and it seems like okay uh
now you're you're again getting
destroyed nothing to be done here you
can't even move the Rook because then
Queen to F7 but now you actually can
play B captures an A1 Queen and after
Queen to H7 check King to F6 and now
look at this Rook captures an A1 and now
it seems that that you will be able to
Checkmate the black king because how are
you stopping this Rook to E1 once it
cuts off the blacking from the file just
one Queen to H6 will be Checkmate again
this will not be possible because of
Queen F7 but the problem is Bishop to B4
guards D1 square and now you're uh the
best you will have is to settle for a
draw here for example check King E7
Queen G7 check King to E8 and now
unfortunately you don't have Rook D1 you
will have to settle for uh Queen G6
checking is seven Queen G7 checking it
and queen to G6 with check so instead
Max says all right since I'm not going
to be able to play Rook to E1 let's
first play Rook to E1 and now we just
repeat what we've discussed but of
course now black will not allow this we
have Queen to F6 uh now the bishop is in
trouble you have to move the bishop
Bishop back to D2 and this is also a
spectacular move and you will soon see
why Bishop to D7 and now uh the problem
is if you play Knight the G5 then Queen
H6 and you are not checkmating
the the black king so here Bishop the C3
by Max absolutely Spectacular Now the
point is if Queen captures on C3 then
Knight to G5 and you can no longer
defend against Checkmate uh that's the
problem so here after this bishop to C3
move uh there is only one good move you
can play and that is Pawn to G6 but it
was not played in the game if Pawn to G6
then you are of course threatening a
trade here and if Queen to H6 then you
can even play Queen captures and C3 and
now let's say Rook the seven white
threatens uh sorry white threatens
Checkmate you will play Rook to F7 and
now after Rook captures King captures
and Rook to E1 again seems like you are
about to finish the job there's Queen to
h8 and okay Knight to G5 with the check
King to G8 and the black king is saved
here unbelievable as it is but black
king survives here Queen captures on G6
Queen to G7 and the black black is even
better but the thing is after Bishop to
C3 Queen the H6 was played and here
there is a problem there is one move
that wins the game for Max so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
this incredible idea while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on always looking for
interesting ways to sacrifice your queen
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Rook the E7 of
course we are going to do it in slow
motion there we go Rook to E7 and now uh
it's you can't even not take the White
Queen let's say you try something like
Rook to F6 you want to give back some
material block the bishop now Queen
captures an H6 now if you capture with
uh with the pond and Bishop captures
Rook so you're gonna have to capture
with the Rook but now Rook captures on
G7 with check King to f8 of course
you're not gonna go under the mask of
the bishop and not just real captures on
D7 and the white position is much much
better white is up a full piece you can
see that the white has a light score
Bishop black doesn't uh this is easy
resigns so of course black said all
right I have to take the queen whatever
happens happens so Queen captures on H5
now comes Rook captures on G7 and we
have the start of a a lot of windmill
action King to 8 and now white can
choose pretty much whatever white wants
you can go for the queen right away with
the Rook to G5 with check you can go uh
for the bishop you can go for some
checks interestingly Max tries Rook to
F7 check which doesn't really do all
that much we have King to G8 and now he
just repeats Rook to G7 check I guess he
was enjoying um all this windmill action
so much he wanted it to last as long as
possible so King to h8 now first you're
gonna grab the bishop and this is uh
something that uh okay uh this is
something that you will even teach a
little children when they learn to play
chess you don't just go for the queen
first check uh how much stuff you can
grab off the board and then only at the
end of the wind windmill you will take
the queen so real characters on D7 with
check and now the problem is if you move
the king now Rook the G7 check into h8
and Rook the G5 check um I will win the
black queen so of course black tries to
avoid this plays Rook to F6 this allows
the black queen to survive because now
the king will be able to go to fa 8 and
now Bishop captures an F6 with check
King to G8 rooked the G7 check King the
f8 and now Knight the G5 so the black
queen survives this but uh can can black
save the game the problem is look at
this if you try to bring the Rook into
the game just Knight H7 check that's it
now black has to give back the queen or
give up the queen and white will be up
too much material so here Bishop
captures an F2 with check this uh will
prevent The Rook from controlling the E
file so Rook captures on F2 and now
Knight the C5 hoping to survive this but
Max just plays Bishop captures on B2 and
now what you play here the The Rook will
just capture on F5 and that's it if you
try running away with the King it's not
all that simple Bishop captures on F5
cuts of the king from escaping and after
something like Queen th8 just Rook the
E2 with check King to d8 or you can go
to f8 it's not much better Rook to F7
checking to Jade and now Bishop to H7
which check forces you to give up the
queen and next move is Checkmate
whatever you do because the bishop
covers h8 and Knight covers the F7
Square so instead after Rook date you
checking the d8 would have to be played
but now it's a matter of Bishop to F6 uh
it's a very nice mate in one or you can
deliver Knight to F7 and Knight mate
nice mate in one or pretty much whatever
you want to do it will still be made in
one you can even throw black and
sacrifice the rook and then play Bishop
to F6 Checkmate even that is possible so
that's why after Bishop captures on B2
um does not start running with his King
he plays Queen to E8 but this just cuts
off the king from going to E8 and now
it's a very nice mate in one of course
you will see it Knight the H7 Checkmate
so truly a spectacular game by Max uh it
seems that we can expect every January
to start like this if Max will be
playing so hopefully I hope he does well
for for the entire year but I'm very
much looking forward to next January uh
if this is on what we can expect so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
like I said uh sorry about not starting
with the Masters Edition but this game
was an absolute must show so I hope you
guys enjoyed that I would like to thank
Francisco masoko randomfill.net Jimbo
Robert Kiefer and the deutron for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
you wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World but
mostly we will be covering the Tata
steel
2023. so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day